when you when you look at like um like
when you were a kid was most of your
relationship with your dad like hockey
like was it tough to cuz if you became
like if you excelled at something early
right and a lot of times Fathers and
Sons will it's tough for Fathers and
Sons to find like a common ground
sometimes to connect on on things you
know parents are always putting their
kids into different things and and dads
are always trying to connect with their
children you know was there other ways
that you could like was that most of
y'all's relationship ship like I'm just
kind of like I guess I'm curious like
what it was like we had a normal
relationship like normal father son my
dad was sort of this hockey father of
the country you know people loved my dad
yeah Walter grety man but I would always
say but it was my mom behind the scenes
that kept her family she was a wonderful
lady and she always kind of stayed out
of the Limelight like when I was a kid
and I'd play all the parents used to sit
sort of together and my mom would sit in
the corner by
herself not to often you can say that
people don't have enemies but I don't
think my dad had an enemy like he was
beloved by everyone um I remember one
time I came home and I when I would go
home and visit them every now and then
you know my dad would tell the whole
city right they coming yeah so I got
smart on that I I I call my mom and I
say I'll be home tomorrow don't tell Dad
so I get there in the morning this is
hilarious and I walk in and there's a
guy lying on the couch yeah I get over
to my mom and I kind of know everybody
that goes in and out of our house you
know my mom was in the kitchen and I
said who's lying on the couch who is
that she goes I don't know um but he's
hitchhiking across the country from
Newland wanted to see the house so your
dad told him to spend the night and have
a good
meal so that's the kind of guy my dad
was and the guy spent the night and got
up in the morning and him and I had
coffee at the din table no way you got
to get a picture with my jersey on when
I happened to be home that day and he
was hi in rest of Canada that was the
kind of dad my dad wow they should put a
they should put him in a jersey and
let's let him hitchhike the country
forever and just make it like a thing
you know yeah well you know it's not the
Stanley Cup but hey guys have you met
Stanley and everybody just picks him up
there you go yeah be funny my dad would
be in the car and after the game he
would say to me his favorite line was
always no matter how good you think you
are there's somebody out there better
than you and I'd say okay and even when
I was 15 16 when people said okay he's
going to be a professional hockey player
my dad never one time said you know oh
he's a c miss or he's going to make it I
mean he hoped cuz he knew how much I
loved it but he never pressured me so we
had an nice rink in my backyard from the
time I was I saw saw I saw some lore
about that yeah so my dad would go and
he would buy a sprinkler head in
December which they always thought he
was crazy who's buying a sprinkler head
Christmas time anyway and he would put
it on the middle of the ice and he would
let it go back and forth for like 2
hours and then go move it another part
of the ice and his ice was always about
this thick and it would last till
probably the end of March did he lay a
good rank oh he had the best really yeah
and he was funny people used to stop by
the house and say how does Walter get
his grass so green what do you do what
are you putting in your grass my dad
didn't do anything it was just probably
from the ice being so good for the the
grass he always had the greenest
the neighborhood and didn't do
anything I my dad used to always tease
me when I was 14 13 14 15 you'd always
say if you do make professional hockey
just remember by I just buy me a
Cadillac yeah so I bought one of those
big Brits Cadillacs I brought it home
right so the summer goes by the year
goes by I go back home the next summer
and I look at the car and there's like
80 mil on it and I go and I said to my
mom I said I bought dad this car why is
he not driving it she goes he does he
can't drive it to work cuz he doesn't
want to have a nicer car than his
boss he ended up I think he sold it I
don't think he really ever drove it but
it was a it was a good fatherson thing
that we had together growing up as a kid
right yeah did you did you speak at your
dad's funeral what was that like yeah I
did I spoke both at my mom and my dad's
um and sorry to hear yeah sorry about
your folk yeah it was you know what it
was funny because there's something that
just takes over inside you that you get
through it right like I remember my mom
passed my dad called me and said you
know will you speak and I said of course
so when my dad was passing my brothers
and my sister said you know will you
speak and I said yeah the ironic thing
was when my dad passed we were still in
the midst of the
pandemic so it was actually in a lot of
ways it was nice for her family cuz
there was only 22 of us there and you
know cuz you couldn't right you couldn't
invite everybody had it had it not been
at that time he probably would had to
get buried or had the funeral in a in a
hockey arena with so many people he so
he was so loved by so many people so
when I I found both times sitting there
going oh this is going to be hard and
when I got up there it just kind of
flowed because my dad when I spoke at
his he was so religious my dad
and you know he never missed Church on a
Sunday went every Sunday and he used to
tease the kids because he tried off for
the church choir and they wouldn't let
him in
it come on bro yeah so there was a
little boy across the street let anybody
disabled and blind and my dad picked
them up every morning at 10:00 a.m.
every Sunday morning at 10:00 a.m. and
took him to church every Sunday and then
brought him back home he taken
McDonald's and then back home and he did
it every Sunday so when my dad was
passing he's so religious but I remember
he was still fighting to stay down here
so to speak um he was 22 days basically
on a deathbed right and U the minister
would come every night at our house and
he would give him his last rights and I
said I say to minister my dad's got the
biggest heart you're coming I'll see you
tomorrow so anyway when when we did give
the uh when I did give
I could feel like he was there and he
got me through it wow that's fascinating
man yeah I remember I went to my dad's f
it was like I don't know it's just such
a Str it's such
a I don't know it's wild seeing
something like that happened I think do
you think it helped that your father had
such a faith did he give you so like a
oh yeah yeah like he knew there was life
after death he was going to see his
mother he's going to see his father so
probably part of him was probably
excited huh yeah I
think yeah in some ways but I think he
wanted to be here as long as he could he
loved being around his grandkids he
loved being around people um he was just
really special in that
sense